[موسيقى]
نرى انه امر اساسي ان لا يتم تسييس
المساعدات الانسانيه او استخدامها كاداه
حتى يستطيع المحتاجون في اي مكان كانوا من
تلقي مساعدات الضروريه اذا نحن
تعاوننا مع كافه الاطراف ذات العلاقه
لضمان توفير المساعدات وينبغي ان اقول
ايضا اننا شاهدنا تضامنا عالميا على نطاق
واسع
[موسيقى]
نحن ما نقوم به هو تقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه وفي الاوضاع التي يحتاج فيها
الناس الوصول الى مساعدات حيويه نقوم
بالتعاون مع كافه الاطراف ذات العلاقه
لضمان تسليم المساعدات وهذا ما نقوم به في
الوقت الراهن رئيسنا
زارا سوريا خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
ونحن نتعاون مع كافه الاطراف على اساس هذا
المبدا المبدا الانساني الذي ينبغي
للاطفال والنساء والكبار السن ان يحصلوا
على المساعدات التي هم بامسه الحاجه لديها
لها
[موسيقى]
اولويتنا هي انقاذ الحيه فورا وتخفيف
المعاناه ولكن ما نعلمه انه في سوريا هذه
الازمه جاءت لتنضم الى ازمتين متواجدتين
منذ سنوات حاولنا ان نوفر الحمايه ونساعد
المجتمعات في سوريا بسبب الصراع وقد تضررت
من ذلك وكذلك
بتردي الاقتصاد وعدم الوصول الى الخدمات
الاساسيه نرى ان نصف الامدادات المياه لا
تعمل جيدا وفي ديسمبر تفشى وباء الكوليرا
اذا نحن نسعى لتجنب تفشي لوباء الكوليرا
من جديد من خلال توفير المياه الصالحه
للشرب وكذلك مستلزمات النظافه
[موسيقى]